une longue colline couleur émeraude posé
sur l'atlantique
comme un doigt de géants pointé vers
l'horizon
au large de la grande terre d'irlande
tout au bout de la péninsule de dingle
se détachent les avant-postes du
continent européen
pendant plusieurs mois de l'année rares
sont ceux qui osent s'approcher de cette
côte inhospitalière parsemé de dentelle
de granit dans ces latitudes extrêmes la
mer la pluie et les vents ont forgé un
peuple à part
ici on a l'oeil aiguisé pour ne pas se
perdre et on parle une langue rugueuse
pour se faire entendre dans cette région
les marins parle encore la langue de
leurs ancêtres irlandais le gaélique
[Musique]
chaque année quand les jours sont les
plus longs fergal quitte le port de
dingle et fait route vers les îles
basket c'est lui le passeur de
l'archipel avec son minuscule ferry
fergal assure les liaisons entre la côte
irlandaise et l'île du grand basket les
rochers que vous voyez là bas sur les
rochers les plus à l'ouest de l'irlande
du contenu ta route vers l'ouest
tu accostera directement en amérique
entre ici et l'amérique
il n'y a pas une seule terre est là
juste derrière moi c'est le phare de
l'île de terreur tu sais le dernier
phare d'europe
[Musique]
séparée de l'irlande par un étroit bras
de mer est souvent caché derrière un
manteau de brume les îles basket
n'existe plus pendant les mois les plus
rudes
[Musique]
pendant l'hiver les vieilles maisons du
village de pêcheurs sont désertes
on pourrait croire que cette partie du
monde a été abandonnée oublier qu'il ne
s'agit là que d'un paradis peuplé
d'oiseaux marins et de moutons sauvages
[Musique]
mais dès que l'air devient plus doux et
que la houle se calme
l'île du grand basket sort de sa torpeur
[Musique]
après une nuit plus que spartiate
les deux frères cela tarde à émerge
doucement issu d'une famille de huit
enfants fergal ekeren ont fait leurs
premières armes de marins à la pêche au
homard à force de relever des casiers
dans les courants et les cailloux ils
ont appris à connaître ce jardin sauvage
quand on avait environ 12 ou 13 ans on a
commencé à venir sur cette île parce que
c'était plus facile quand on allait à la
pêche on tirait notre bateau sur la cale
et puis on rester ici plusieurs jours
dans cette maison avec mon autre frère
et depuis cette maison la garder j'ai
beaucoup de tendresse pour cet endroit
c'est un lieu d'une grande beauté c'est
un endroit magique
il n'y a pas de route pas de voiture pas
l'électricité
c'est vraiment paisible pas grand monde
dans ce coin reculé d'irlande
d'ailleurs pour rencontrer les rares
habitants de l'île il faut soit allé
chercher soit les attendre patiemment
donna rhymes et oui sans lever à 5h ce
matin ils sont partis à l'autre bout de
l'île pour rassembler les moutons je
pense qu'il devrait rentrer tout à
l'heure vers 11 heures
turgeon
après quatre heures de marche en
direction de l'ouest dont un rat et
sheamus s'aperçoivent enfin un pic des
falaises une partie de leur troupeau
dispersé avec leurs chiens les berges et
tente une opération difficile avant de
les rassembler dans un enclos ils
doivent faire en sorte que les bêtes ne
se précipite pas vers la mer
chaque année au début de l'été donne à s
es amis débarquent sur l'île pour des
transhumances un peu spécial les piétons
que j'ai ce sont ceux qui se trouvent
près des falaises là-bas au loin vers
l'ouest de l'île
ça prend beaucoup de temps pour tous les
rassembler les maîtriser si tu fais le
moindre mauvais geste tu peux les perdre
à nouveau dans les falaises et quand on
arrive du côté du village là on a un peu
plus de chance parce que les chiens
peuvent mieux les encercler moi j'ai
trois règles premièrement tu dois
pouvoir rentrer chez toi deuxièmement tu
ramènes tes chiens et à la fin si tu
peux tu ramènes avec toi quelques
moutons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ton fatigué sans épuiser faut dire qu'on
a fait un long voyage
sur le papier les berges et des baskets
sont bien européens même s'ils vivent
aux confins du continent mais il n'est
pas toujours facile pour eux de jongler
avec l' envie de faire subsister leurs
traditions et leur situation
géographique
un peu particulière nous sommes à
l'extrême ouest de l'europe et en même
temps nous sommes le point le plus
proche de la mairie
d'ailleurs sentons souvent que nous
avons plus de liens avec l'amérique avec
l'italie par exemple les pays du centre
de l'europe surtout avec les migrations
qu'on a eues ici depuis des années et
des années ils sont tous partis aux
états unis donc on a souvent plus de
connaissances à boston ou à new york
qu'à paris ou rome on n'a rien contre
l'europe mais c'est vrai que notre lien
traditionnel c'est l'amérique
oui
[Musique]
sur l'archipel des baskets il fallait
souvent choisir entre l'horizon avec la
promesse d'une vie meilleure sur les
côtes américaines et la grande-terre
d'irlande tout aussi inconnu
[Musique]
et
avant la première guerre mondiale on
comptait près de 160 habitants sur la
colline mais les conditions de vie
difficile pousse les îliens à l'exode
en 1947 il ne reste plus sur l'île
qu'une cinquantaine de villageois et
puis un jour de novembre en 1953 le
gouvernement irlandais décide de faire
évacuer l'île définitivement après le
décès d'un habitant n'ayant pas pu être
soignés à cause de la tempête
les dernières famille embarque avec
seulement quelques valises sous le bras
triste mais en même temps en soulagé de
quitter une vie à la merci des humeurs
de l'océan
[Musique]
la plupart de ceux qui habitaient sur
l'île ont émigré vers les états unis
mais une poignée d'entre eux sont restés
en irlande maureen donne la vie a vécu
sur les baskets quand elle était enfant
sa mère était institutrice de la petite
école de lille elle y est toujours une
maison mais n'ose plus traverser on a
gardé cette petite maison parce qu'on y
est très attaché mon père mon grand père
ont été élevés dans cette maison et puis
il y avait surtout mon frère pas de
règle qui passait toutes ses vacances il
y allait dès qu'il y avait un moment
j'espère qu'elle doit encore tenir le
coup encore quelques années
en 1953 maurice greene était un jeune
homme d'une trentaine d'années lui aussi
a préféré rester dans le village de john
quinn juste en face de son île
on avait quitté les îles plaskett la
veille de noël
mais le temps a changé comme ça d'un
seul coup je me rappelle encore on avait
plein de nourriture des pommes de terre
et du poisson mais pas de bougies pour
s'éclairer
non j'étais pas triste de quitter mon
île on est finalement parti le 27
décembre
mais au fond de nous on savait bien
qu'on allait revenir au mois de juin
pour tondre les moutons jusqu'au mois de
juillet par la suite pendant des années
c'est ce qu'on a toujours fait jusqu'à
ce qu'on devienne un peu trop vieux je
pense souvent au mauvais temps qu'on
avait sur les îles basket et surtout à
la vie très rude qu'on devait supporter
parfois mais on était trop jeune pour
comprendre quand on y pense maintenant
on n'avait pas de cure et pas de
médecins pas de bateau pour aller sur la
côte
tout cela m'angoisse un peu quand j'y
pense aujourd'hui je connaissais chaque
rocher chaque grotte chaque recoin
m'était familier vous voyez ça c'est la
plage blanche
on pêchait delà jusqu'au sud de l'île
enfin quand il faisait beau
et quand le soleil brille sur les
baskets fergal et son jeune frère ne
chôme pas car les îles les plus à
l'ouest ne vivent désormais que pendant
trois mois l'été par temps calme
vingt bonnes minutes suffisent pour
traverser à partir de l'abri de john
quinn sur le continent mais lorsque les
courants de marée deviennent trop fort
comme aujourd'hui le moindre écart de
cap ne pardonne pas fergal sait que ses
jours de travail sont comptés
ne s'émeut
entre l'île de la grande glace kate et
la côte
il ya tout un tas de récits sous marins
il y en a notamment deux gros qu'on ne
peut pas voir la mer devient très
mauvaise quand le courant et le vent
sont opposés et dans ces moments là il
faut être très attentif surtout quand on
a des gens à bord
parfois on est un peu surpris ils vont
tourner d'un seul coup ce matin par
exemple on a écouté la météo ils ont dit
qu'il y aurait un peu de vent et que la
mère ne serait pas trop mauvaises
aujourd'hui mais là il est une heure de
l'après-midi et depuis midi le vent
tourne
ça va encore pour l'instant vous savez
on fait ce métier depuis pas mal
d'années maintenant
au fil du temps on a appris comment
réagir
il faut savoir qu'ici il n'y a pas de
vrai call que ce soit sur l'idée de la
sq est tous dans le port de den queen
sur la côte
c'est donc très difficile d'accoster
caen la mer devient houleuse il ya bien
un petit débarcadère sur l'île mais
c'est compliqué d'y accéder lorsqu'il
fait mauvais en hiver on ne pourrait
même pas sortir pendant deux ou trois
mois
un peu plus haut sur la falaise donnera
profite lui aussi des éclaircies pour
soigner et ondres ces bêtes avant
l'hiver l'ancien instituteur a quitté
l'école du port de dingle pour se
consacrer uniquement à sa vocation de
berger sans lui il n'y aurait sans doute
plus d'activités sur l'archipel de nacre
a choisi les baskets parce qu'ici
l'herbe est arrosé par les embruns la
viande de mes moutons un goût spécial
parce qu'ici l'herbe et différente ce
n'est pas la même que sur le continent
c'est une arme très saine avec ça au
moins les bêtes n'ont pas de maladie sur
le continent les gens connaissent cette
viande vous savez des animaux prés salés
des baskets sont très prisés thomass et
sheamus s'expriment tous dans leur
langue maternelle le gaélique
cette langue est encore parlé dans la
péninsule de dingle et dans bien
d'autres communautés de la côte ouest de
l'irlande dans les alentours on ne parle
que gaélique c'est notre langue courante
entre nous on ne parle jamais autre
chose
bien évidemment ici tout le monde sait
parler anglais
on doit pouvoir communiquer avec
l'extérieur pour chaque endroit
nous avons une terminologie
traditionnels ce sont des mots que nous
avons appris de ceux qui étaient là
avant nous et c'est vrai que ça nous
ferait bizarre de changer d'utiliser des
termes anglais quand on est ensemble on
continue à se servir des termes
traditionnel pour les collines la mer ou
les moutons comme ça qu'on l'a appris on
le porte en nous et on ne pourrait pas à
l'exprimer autrement de tous
[Musique]
tout au bout de la vieille europe les
descendants des baskets se battent pour
leur langue le gaélique fait partie de
l'héritage de ces îles occidentales
c'est ici dans les ruines d'un village
fantôme que le poète dany qui a
découvert une source d'inspiration
intarissable
[Musique]
dans chaque maison du village
je ne voyais que muraille détruites et
cheminées effondrées
mais en lisant les manuscrits des
anciens j'ai compris qu'ici régnait un
esprit de liberté dans les années 30
les îliens vos défilés une succession
d'hommes de lettres venues apprendre une
langue gaélique encore peu touchées par
l'anglais et les influences de la vie
continental la rencontre improbable
entre ces savants et érudits et des
insulaires endurci par la mère donne
naissance à la publication de plusieurs
livres parmi les auteurs une femme
extérieur et un marin pêcheur tomasso
prime
cet homme simple des baskets ne
s'attendait pas à ce que ces histoires
fasse le tour du monde
son livre l'homme des il est aujourd'hui
traduit en plusieurs langues
voici la cheminée est là dans ces deux
petits trous il mettait sa pipe et son
tabac je pense que de ce côté il y avait
sa table et plus loin vers le bas il y
avait sa chambre avec juste au dessus un
petit grenier
bien sûr ils acceptaient leur vie
insulaire
il avait plusieurs moyens de la rendre
un peu meilleur vous avez leurs
traditions orales leurs chansons la
poésie la musique et la danse grâce à
toute cette vie communautaire le
quotidien avait beau être durs cela leur
a permis de tenir
[Musique]
oui
le dos tourné à l'océan
les marins et les paysans des baskets
n'avait finalement que leur joie de
vivre et un peu d'insouciance pour
lutter contre les allemands et supporter
les caprices de la mer
[Musique]
m
un drôle de scarabées noir descend le
long de la cale de john quinn après
avoir relevé ses casiers à homard dans
les cailloux de l'archipel paddy
s'offrent une petite sortie en mer à
bord de son et wang le canoë
traditionnel des baskets c'est sur cette
frêle embarcation avec son compère pod
qu'il a appris son métier de caseyeur de
temps en temps quand la mère n'est pas
trop mauvaise
il lui arrive encore d'aller pêcher le
homard sur son i walk la première fois
que j'ai mis le pied sur l'un de ces
bateaux
j'ai vraiment ressenti quelque chose de
spécial pour la mère et la pêche
d'ailleurs la première fois que je suis
sorti au maire c'était avec padraig
quand j'étais gamin je n'avais jamais vu
de voile sur ce genre de bateau
je savais que ça existait parce que
j'avais vu des photos c'est par chance
que j'ai eue cette voile je les récupère
et quand ça donnera dont l'un des
parents étaient pêcheurs dans l'archipel
des black cats il paraît que c'était un
excellent péchin regarde-moi sept voiles
elle est belle elle tient toujours je
pense qu'elle a au moins 60 ans
j'imagine qu'elle a dû en faire des
voyages entre les îles et la terre ferme
[Musique]
sur la colline des baskets la course
reprend de plus belle
[Musique]
cette fois de la fable profité de la
marée haute pour faire transiter une
partie de son troupeau sur beinish l'un
des îlots de l'archipel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant on avance bien mais c'est
pas facile de les faire descendre ce
sont des moutons sauvages mais on a de
bons chiens et surtout de l'aide
l'entr'aide c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
important
je ne suis pas tout seul à faire ce
boulot depuis toujours on se rassemble
d'ailleurs pour travailler ici on
appelle ça le mail un petit groupe
d'hommes se rassemblent pour en aider un
autre
et puis après on fait la même chose pour
celui qui aurait besoin qu'on lui coupe
ces mauvaises herbes
on contourne ses moutons par exemple
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
key
il faut faire vite avant que les
courants ne s'inverse en un peu plus
d'une demi heure une cinquantaine de
moutons est embarqué sur les zodiac
avant d'être relâché sur une autre île
à la fin de l'été l'opération sera
répétée mais cette fois les berges et
regagneront définitivement le continent
avec l'ensemble du troupeau
[Musique]
pour
on a plus de mille moutons sur l'autre
il est là bas tout au bout on ne peut
pas aller les chercher tous les jours on
mettrait plus de six heures à chaque
fois et c'est plus facile de venir les
chercher ici
l'autre raison pour laquelle on les
déplace ici c'est que cette île c'est un
très bon endroit pour un agneau qui
serait faible et qui aurait besoin
d'engraisser un petit peu là les moutons
ne me restait que quelques semaines
ensuite on viendra les chercher ce
travail c'est notre nature il fait
partie de nous on aime être ici on aime
le paysage c'est un peu plus difficile
qu'ailleurs mais tout le travail se fait
en été après tu peux passer tout l'hiver
sur le continent sans rien faire
cette île taureaux jeunes
elle te change complètement si au moins
tu ne t'en dort pas comme sur le
continent
tu change vraiment moi je trouve qu'on
prend beaucoup de plaisir à vivre ici
cet endroit tu mets vraiment du baume au
coeur il te rend plus vivant
il est grand temps pour le berger des
baskets de ramener son troupeau sur la
grande terre avant que les premières
dépression 2 se profile à l'horizon et
que les brumes de l'atlantique ne rende
l'archipel invisible aux confins de
l'europe
l'été s'achève plutôt qu'ailleurs même
les pêcheurs se rapproche de la côte
histoire de laisser sans dormir
tranquillement les îles basket
[Musique]
pour faire gala le passeur c'est aussi
la fin de la saison
désormais son ferry restera bien à
l'abri sur les quais du port de dingle
de nara fergal sheamus et paddy savent
qu'ils se retrouveront dans quelques
mois sur les sentiers de la longue
colline des baskets à leur manière ils
donneront encore un peu d'âme à cet
archipel oublié